let me pick up next on our caller from
the 772 area code 772 what's your name
and where you calling from hi yes it is
hi my name is andrew from jacksonville
florida
hey andrew what's going on i just wanted
to get your your opinion about Kelly Ann
Connolly and her husband George Conway
and dynamic is between them and I have a
theory that she's the one that wrote
that New York Times op-ed resistance
piece and that she is completely on
board with George Conway's critiques of
the president it's interesting you
mentioned that so you're not the first
person that has suggested to me that
it's Kelly Anne Conway who wrote that
anonymous critique of the Trump
administration for people who don't know
Kelly Anne Conway is an advisor to
Donald Trump and very public Trump
defender her husband George Conway is a
Republican who has been one of trumps
absolute biggest critics funding all
sorts of anti Trump ads and I mean it's
so so people are having a hard time
understanding how it is that they're
just living together at home like how is
it possible that these two people could
live together so one of the ideas is
exactly what Andrew is suggesting which
is Kent they actually are on the same
page when it comes to Trump and
Kellyanne is just publicly remaining
positive about Trump but privately
actually is on board with George Conway
I don't know the answer but I've
I don't understand how their
relationship works because you know
you've got James Carville and Mary
Matalin Democratic and Republican
strategists who are married but they it
seems as though they've figured out a
way where they're both they're not
really fighting each other in on any
individual race typically Conway and
Conway Kellyanne and George I don't get
how it works and your idea that maybe
behind the scenes they actually both
hate Trump is certainly a possibility
yeah I agree
oh can I just ask you one more question
yeah what how do you take your coffee
and lay
what style of coffee do I almost
exclusively I'm drinking espresso Brit
based drinks right now I'm not really
like a drip or filter coffee guy so
typically you know standard six ounce
cappuccino is my go-to certainly in the
morning and then you know I might make a
half-caf now that it's quarantine I'm
making everything at home so I can make
a half-caf iced latte now that it's
warmer in the afternoon or you know
could be a macchiato if I'm feeling
crazy maybe I'll just have an espresso
but I am I'm mostly away from drip
coffee and filter coffee and on espresso
okay I do you ever dream on tape being
from Argentina you know I doubt I'm not
a big fan of it I'm just I've never it's
never been a big thing for me okay of
course all right thank you so much great
to hear from you a perfect phone call I
would say ladies and gentlemen